Cinnamon. Cordial is a
distilled spirit that is
both sweet and spicy.
It's this complexity of
flavor that is at the
heart of its appeal.
This particular cinnamon
cordial starts with a
blend of California
grape brandy that's been
aged two years.
The distiller measures
the amount, the recipe
calls for and pours it
into the main production
vessel. He then pumps
neutral grain spirits out
of a big holding tank
and into the measuring
bucket. This spirit is
190 proof, which means
that it's 95% alcohol.
He adds it to the grape
brandy.
Together, the brandy and
the neutral spirits will
serve as the alcohol
base for the cinnamon
cordial. The brandy
contributes color and a
little flavor, while the
clear spirits add
potency.